how much weight did you lose playing
christopher mccandless how much weight
did how much did you weigh so for end of
the wild
i remember i was 156
when i got the part because i hadn't
gotten on a scale
in ages and i remember i got on the
scale and i was like
dad like my scale's broken i need will
you get me a new one
and he's like i'll pick you up one at
walmart and then he like brought me a
new scale that i got on and i was like
this scale is broken too man i think my
dad was like
maybe the scale's not broken and i was
like oh it's
oh whoa um so
i remember sean sean wanted me to get
pretty lean because the real chris was
he was pretty lean even before he
had that big weight loss so uh
i lost probably went down to like 133
from 156. just to get into like the
shape for the movie for the normal parts
and then we shot like half the movie
and i was doing a lot of like running
every day and eating healthy and
you know spin and uh
and then there was like a two week
shutdown
in the middle of the shoot and i had
gone down probably to like 124
and then i had two weeks so i was doing
like two spin
classes a day and like eating like the
bare minimum
and at one point dude two spin classes a
day on no food was
so hard like i don't know if you've ever
done that probably haven't but no
it's like psychologically like it is so
like it's like me
you're just like oh it like hurts
it doesn't physically hurt but like it
psychically hurts
and i remember i would like sit up
in those like two or three weeks and
like my vision would go totally orange
for like
15 seconds like literally blind i
remember i texted my doctor i was like
hey doc
i'm going blind when i'm sitting up like
every time and he was like oh you need
to
take some salt because that's like low
blood pressure so i did that
and then that kind of went away so then
i went down to like 115
pounds we went to alaska yeah and then i
was there and we
shot the good news was is we shot most
of those scenes
in like six day period so i was like
crazy skinny
but like on like the third or fourth day
like i could like
feel like my heart like palpitating
like i could actually feel it like boom
and i was like oh [ __ ]
so i told him i was like we gotta finish
these scenes because i can like feel i
don't have much time to like keep
shooting this
this is like probably not safe that is
insane
i mean you know i watched these shows
you ever watched like alone the shows
alone where people
heard of it it's funny my friend one of
my friend from childhood
his brother is like on alone right now
really
yeah well they dropped them off and it's
real i mean they're alone
and whoever lasts the longest is the
winner
and it's it's crazy the [ __ ] that they
do
but they have doctors that come in every
i don't know when it is every week to
just check on them check their vitals
now someone who is 159 or whatever you
were in the beginning
to drop down to 115 were they always
monitoring you
were they always making sure hey he's
okay i mean because that's that
sounds pretty dangerous i had a really
talented doctor um
that the insurance company had me work
with and he was really experienced and
he
was one of the main doctors on biggest
loser so i was kind of consulting with
him but then at a certain point i did
i you know the last few pounds i think
that
i wasn't like approved to lose you know
what i mean
but i'm also you know i'm like five six
and a half
five seven i mean i would actually
i'd still say that like i've seen
way more extra i mean i don't look at
that as like a weight loss
kind of i mean it's a weight loss role
but i don't look at it like that i look
at like what
jared leto did in dallas fires club or
what bale did in the machinist or even
what matt damon did
in courage under fire i actually think
those dudes lost
like more weight you know i think it
feels like i lost a lot lot more weight
because of the
environment in the in the within the
story too and the character is
starving and all that so it like it
really seems like it
but if you actually were to compare my
like height and body mass and everything
to some of those other ones like i think
there's actors that have lost more for
sure
for sure wow